So here are our population parameters. Let's say that I want to bring up this
ratio. So I want more people to watch more of the lessons, so I'm going to spice
things up. Well in lesson nine you're going to learn how to formally determine
whether or not something had an effect. This is called hypothesis testing. And
I'm thinking about writing a song on how hypothesis testing works and then
singing it for you in the next lesson. Like, for example, do you remember
learning the quadratic formula? X equals negative b plus or minus the square
root of b squared minus 4ac. All over 2a and those are the roots of a quadratic
function. Some people learned it in middle school as a song and maybe that made
learning it a lot more fun. So I'm thinking about writing a song on hypothesis
testing. And by the way, this is no joke, I'm seriously considering this.
However, I don't want to run the risk of a song hurting rather than helping your
engagement with the course material. So, maybe I'll create the next lesson with
the song, but only make it available to a random sample of 20 students. And I
won't force them to watch it, I'll just do the same thing I always do, just make
it available every week, just like I make the other lessons available. Then I'll
look at this ratio. Let's pretend that for this sample we get that the mean
ratio is 0.13.